test your pricing
if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur you want to make a lot of
money you've got to see what the right
price is for your market and you won't
know until you actually go
and test it most entrepreneurs
undervalue themselves under price
themselves and end up struggling to get
by
instead of being able to build a highly
successful company
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hunger entrepreneurs deserve help
and today i'm answering a question from
a youtube viewer love you guys thank you
for writing in
intuitive heart healer intuitive heart
healer who wrote in to say hi evan i
found your videos i enjoy them thank you
my question to you
is this how do you go about finding
sponsors for youtube videos and more
importantly how do you figure out
what to charge them so for me
sponsorship on the youtube videos has
not been
one of the revenue streams that i'm
going after there are some ads that
might show up
um it's all run through youtube so
youtube finds
the partners it doesn't make a ton of
money i'm not making it rich off youtube
videos it's more to answer questions for
you guys
but if you are going to go out and find
a sponsor the typical way
that you would value it is based on a
number of views on your videos
so you could say i haven't checked your
channel so i don't know how many views
you have on your videos but for every
thousand views on your videos you're
gonna charge five bucks
eight bucks whatever makes sense and if
i were doing it i would also package in
an opportunity to be featured in the
video so if you are
showcasing their tools showcasing their
company
interviewing their president whatever
you can think of to do a video that's of
interest to your audience it's not just
a sales pitch
but helping them discover this great
company that you
passionately believe in then you could
charge more for it
so you might be able to charge a
sponsorship fee per video
and say it's five dollars per thousand
people who visit
and then you can also charge a
promotional piece where you are
showcasing
that company and sharing information
about them and why you think they're
great
and that could be a set fee maybe it's a
thousand dollars maybe it's 500
maybe it's 250 again whatever makes
sense you have to test
out your pricing start it
at a number that you feel is fair and
see what the reaction is
and then from there you can start
increasing your prices when i first
started doing
writing for big brands
i started off at 500 to do a piece
and people are really interested in that
it's like okay this is great i get 500
bucks
and i get the link to my own website
this is this is great this is bonus
i got too much demand i had i had too
many people coming to me who wanted to
do this and i didn't have enough time
to do it so i started increasing my
prices it was a thousand dollars
then it was fifteen hundred dollars and
now it's twenty five hundred dollars do
the same thing
and that seems to be the point for me
that seems to be the max
people people resist more on that price
so you can start off low you can start
off maybe a little bit under
what you think it should be at the end
and start
boosting yourself up as you get more
interest
see if it works it should the the
challenge for a lot of people who have
youtube channels is they don't get a lot
of views
so if you're basing on a thousand views
if you're making five bucks per thousand
views
which would still be a pretty good price
how many views are you getting on your
videos
right again i haven't checked out your
video so i don't want to assume that's
not a lot
but a lot of times the videos just are
not popular enough
so it might be really targeted which is
great but you have to have views to make
it count where you think you'll make
bigger money especially at the start is
if you do those promotional pieces
and you showcase why you like that
company good place to start but for any
entrepreneur
test your pricing at the start you're
just trying to get to survival
you're just trying to make enough money
to pay your bills so you don't have to
go back and get a job
okay but as you get better at what you
do as you become the expert you need to
start increasing your prices
and testing to see where your customers
start resisting because most
entrepreneurs could boost their prices
by 30 percent and if they're offering
incredible value
the customers won't care they won't
resist they'll keep paying
and you won't know that until you
actually go out and test it
so always be testing your prices and see
where you can bump it up because that
extra money goes right into your pocket
and i want you to have money in your
pocket thank you guys for watching you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below and i want to hear what you
have to think
please leave a comment under this video
with your thoughts and if you have a
question let me know i want to hear from
you
i want to make a video reply for you
thank you so much and i'll see you on
the next episode